the planet has been taken father the
third I came pledge his eternal loyalty
to your cause accept my terms
well done daughter well done
why
by the look of it you seem content
enough at the time
that's right refused
after my planet died I had nothing no
one when I thought I never would I was
alright with that I had a new vocation
and I found you and at my side you
became the fiercest woman in the galaxy
[Music]
that's why I chose you to find the soul
stone I'm sorry I disappointed you I am
disappointed not because you didn't find
it
because you did
and you lied I gave you my trust paid it
with deceit at least be honest about it
now it could make you tell me you seem
to know that I never wanted to force you
into anything
that's why
when you left me all those years ago I
allowed it you allowed it
you haven't been under the impression
you escaped daughter I raised us you
didn't raise me you kidnapped me
orphaned me and imprisoned me everything
I hate about myself comes from you I
stayed because you taught me I didn't
deserve
I found people that shot me I did you
had a family here that wouldn't know we
just didn't care what happened to it
[Music]
[Music]
yippy chimera lovers it's Jan here with
the infinity war blu-ray release we're
finally getting to see the movies
deleted scenes and the one you just saw
is one of the things the Russo brothers
were referring to when they said there
was more backstory for Thanos that got
the chop from the finished film this
deleted scene takes place in the throne
room on Thanos his sanctuary ship and
would have occurred after Thanos took
Gamora from the Guardians having tricked
them with the reality stone on nowhere
okay let's look in more detail at some
interesting points in the deleted scene
notice that red flash there will that
stun us using the reality stone to
create a flashback of sorts to remind
Gamora what her life was like with him
we get to see Gamora acting as one of
palaces and forces exacting tributes
from rulers she even brings in the head
of a king who presumably wouldn't
acquiesce to thanasis demands Gomorrah
and thanasis feelings about their shared
history are diametrically opposed he
sees gamora's having become a warrior
thanks to him and she sees herself as
having been his prisoner remember the
actual movie only shows us Gamora as a
young child with Thanos so this moment
in the deleted scene is an interesting
bit of show rather than tell backstory
for her character as well as Stannis's
warped view of their relationship the
deleted scene also confirms how much he
views Gamora as his favorite daughter
saying that by his side she became the
fiercest woman in the galaxy we've seen
and heard about this favoritism before
in the Guardians films and how painful
it was for gamora's adoptive sister
never alone that's why I trusted you to
find the source
I'm sorry I disappointed you
I'm disappointed but not because I
didn't find it
but because you did
and you lied the beginning of the
exchange between Thanos and Gomorrah
about the soul stone is almost exactly
the same in the deleted scene as it is
in the final movie that's why I chose
you to find the soul stone I'm sorry I
disappointed you I am disappointed not
because you didn't find it
because you did
and you lied however after Thanos
reveals that Gamora lied to him about
the soul stones the deleted scene
continues with further details whereas
the final movie cuts immediately to
nebula being tortured in this extended
part of the deleted scene Thanos reveals
that when Gamora left him back in the
first guardians of the galaxy movie she
didn't escape as she believed instead he
allowed her to leave gomorrah's reaction
to Stannis calling her daughter is
basically the same but a bit longer than
the version in the final film I raised
you didn't raise me you kidnapped me
orphaned me and imprisoned me everything
I hate about myself
comes from you for time you had that
same will as you fought by my side
daughter
I'm not your daughter
the deleted scene also ends differently
with Thanos portaling to where he's
holding nebula prisoner rather than
opening a huge Doris happens in the
actual movie when you compare this
deleted scene to what we saw in the
final film it actually feels more like
an alternate or extended scene than a
truly deleted scene the scene in the
movie had a much more dramatic opening
with Gamora tossing the food her father
brings her against his throne which
immediately and clearly reinforces the
antagonism between father and daughter
the deleted scene also doesn't include
the moment where Thanos tells Gamora how
her planet is thriving ever since he
killed half of its population
we were happy on my home planet going to
bed hungry scrounging for scraps your
planet was on the brink of collapse
I'm the one who stopped that you know
what's happened since then the children
born have known nothing but full bellies
and clear skies it's a paradise
because you have to plan it's a small
price to pay for salvation that was an
important character moment for Thanos as
it shows the twisted logic he's
constructed for himself to justify his
plan for the universe and of course it's
also an important piece of exposition
for the audience to understand better
what Thanos has in mind later when he
snaps his fingers and turns half of
humanity to dust so while I think that
bit of extra backstory for Gamora would
have also been interesting to see in the
movie overall the final version we got
was definitely more dramatic snappier
and worked better it was also a bit
shorter which I imagine was another
consideration for the Russo brothers
given infinity Wars already long runtime
by the way originally there were more
Thanos backstory scenes in an earlier
infinity war script according to the
screenwriters a scene was cut which
showed how Thanos was rejected by his
own people on his home planet of Titan
and another scene was chopped which
showed how the mad Titan recruited the
black order so what do you think about
this bonus Sansa and Gamora scene would
you like to have seen it in the movie
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below
tapleft to watch deleted scenes from
ant-man and the wasp or tap write for my
full Marvel movies playlist
congratulations to my ant-man and the
wasp giveaway winner send me an email
with your details so I can get your
present out to you thanks for watching
and see you next time you became movie
lovers